joining us now with more on this the
author of a brand-new book just out
today billionaire at the barricades the
populist revolution from Reagan the
Trump in bookstores now hosts of the
soon-to-be upcoming show at 10:00 p.m.
following this show every night a rare
in studio appearance how are you good
what's up miss you're gonna be throwing
the me at ten o'clock I'm gonna be
throwing so can you can you catch hello
it can throw better than you can it's
road to Rio royal yeah great you dropped
a drop that well it was a surprise
victory
I am tired every two and four years yeah
conservative racist sexist homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic it's a it's a
lie and they get away with the lie the
Weinstein thing is a it's it's a big
deal I've heard rumors about this back
in 1999 friends of mine who worked in
the modeling industry and worked the
entertainment I have all my friends in
the model well you know they're the
friends that you'd hang out with in your
construction but they mentioned some
things about YC I didn't really know who
he was but it sounded pretty gross but
this is part of the reason why so many
working-class Americans have tuned out
to the so called experts on the left and
politics because they claim that whether
it's Sandra Fluke who comes around--
along and says well there's a war on
women out there it's being waged by
Republicans no one takes them seriously
I don't take them seriously when
michelle malkin or other conservative
women are attacked on college campuses
they never speak out to defend them you
be shouted down whatever it's it's we're
now just used to it but it's one thing
if you're really for women whatever they
believe but they're not they're only for
you if you ascribe to a certain set of
you but isn't it if if Hillary takes
money from Weinstein and silent
throughout this whole price Michelle
Obama has she spoken out you know might
have missed well they've taken money
from - just like in the campaign I
couldn't believe that there was no
outrage over the millions and millions
that she took from countries where men
tell women at address to death killing
gays and lesbians again there is no
moral certitude when it comes to the the
left because they
are about conglomerating more power in
washington that keeping the big
international institutions afloat and
depriving the deplorable of power to run
their own lives that's the whole point
they don't trust the voters these people
don't trust the regular work a day
Americans to make decisions for their
own lives they think Washington should
make those decisions so if you believe
in the whatever the climate change
agenda the abortion agenda reformulating
the family whatever their issue of the
day is if you stand with them they'll go
though they'll defend you to each other
shamed it I don't like being lied about
because guess what
I love women I'm not the caricature that
they paint right you know for all these
years they got one playbook it's every
election yeah the one worn mammograms
Trump is a protect remember a year ago I
was looking back on this cuz you and I
are on the air a year ago they were
saying that if Trump got elected that
the global economy would tank because
he's going to be a protectionist and an
isolationist that the US markets would
collapse on election night you had
people on other cable channels warning
people and saying sell our obituaries
our obituary you I was reading your book
and this is fascinating to me I've
always been a Reagan conservative yeah
you know tell me one part of Trump's
agenda maybe trade would be one that's
not what Reagan did to get the economy
going what I want you to count rage on
remember Reagan saved Harley Davidson by
Sterling import taxes on cheap Japanese
motorcycles and George W Bush saw the
populist approach in in taxing with
imports of cold-rolled cheap steel
coming from China and Asia so Obama did
a little tariffs Trump wants to do more
tariffs Bush saw the wisdom of that and
the Republican Party has been a quote
protectionist party that's true but
guess what they're protecting American
workers so Trump taps into that
understanding that mentality a year ago
just like fair trade yeah well no trade
is great but it's it trade is in a
theory that we
at the American Enterprise Institute on
a Saturday afternoon that's not true
trade is something that we believe in
because it betters the life of the
average American that's what Trump is
done with what Steve banners up after
you and and it's amazing to me these
corker tapes at the level of he goes
right to the New York Times notice it it
that tells you these were gonna be
released he goes right here in New York
Times I think I think cork corker Sean
is a bush Republican you meet him he's a
nice guy but he's always been squirrely
about Trump Iran and if I'm gonna tell
the Fox viewers something that I didn't
write in the book I ran into bob corker
at an airport about I think it was April
or May of 2016 I guess it was May of 26
June right after Trump was it was
clearly gonna be the nominee and he was
very uncomfortable the idea of Trump as
the nominee saying well and I said you
should talk to him you should meet with
Donald Trump I think you'd actually
you'd see what what he's what he's all
about it's about the regular person the
working people make this country begging
to be Secretary of screaming no I know I
didn't want of course he did he wanted
to be Secretary of State he thought that
he might actually be the vice
presidential pick yeah all right so
you're going on a book tour
which is the reason why you can't be
here for the next two weeks okay give me
a break I only write a book every four
years I'm likes all right the book is
phenomenal right there and you go to my
website your website and we have the
listed people are going to hear you
speak and by the way in the back I don't
know what happened on that part but he's
been teasing about this cover that is
well I like the front cover and read
black lives matter
you are bizarre I'll be in Philly on
Thursday than Myrtle Beach on Friday
Oklahoma City Monday or you please sign
a copy for me yeah I guess now I know
I'm sure I won't I